es war wie beim ausverkauf jeder wollte
dabei seien 2010 im museum of modern art
bei der retrospektive von marina
abramovic drei monate lang saß sie acht
stunden am tag auf einem stuhl und
schalter leute an 1500 menschen setzen
sich ihr gegenüber und viele schauten zu
woher plötzlich dieses interesse an
performance kunst im museum hat die
kunstwelt genug von fetisch objekten die
sich nur noch ums geld drehen
oder ist die performance die neueste
form der ablenkung im gesättigten
kunstmarkt
das versprechen von performance kunst
dass man über ganz einfache gesangs und
über über gesten physische präsenz und
über bewegung kommunizieren
das hat wir neue virulenz erfahren unter
anderem die kommunikationsmittel
heutzutage haben dass das man sehr viel
über die bildschirme fahren das heißt
was der lebendig ich habe und dass die
unmittelbare interaktion neue welt
erfahren hat
es ist noch nicht lange her da war die
performance eine randerscheinung der
kunstwelt
jetzt ist alles anders höhepunkt an der
diesjährigen art basel waren 14 räumen
gefüllt mit live performance ist die
begegnung mit echten menschen stahl dem
verkaufsobjekt die show ist diese
vergängliche kunst einer gegenreaktion
auf die käuflichkeit von fast allem was
der markt zu bieten hat es geht ja wie
zwei diskussionspunkt einem sitz wirksam
performance signal der kritik
neoliberale praktiker metrum es anders
macht vom objekt wegzug von grund macht
fraktion suite und das stimmt sicher
dass performance noch nicht die
akzeptanz hat und in dem sie nur am
markt hat aber andersrum bedient
performance natürlich die weltkultur und
mediengesellschaft und social media
es ist natürlich es weiter so viel
inhalt generiert und es gibt verbreitet
vom museums in hart wie das noch nicht
der fall ist
letztes wochenende in der stadt wie vor
jenny jetzt bereitet die diesjährige
skulpturenausstellung vor objekte sind
weit und breit keine zu sehen
er hat künstler beauftragt den
öffentlichen raum mit performances zu
bespielen die begegnung zwischen kunst
und passant spannendes und und völlig zu
einer konfrontation führen
die kunst der performance ist eine
mischung aus minimaler gäste und im
lechzen nach maximale aufmerksamkeit
tino sehgal der künstler der
aufmerksamkeit und vergänglichkeit am
radikalsten vereint ist tino sehgal
seine werke bestehen im grunde nur aus
personen die nach seinen anweisungen
gespräche und gesten im museum ausführen
sogar das guggenheim museum in new york
wurde leer geräumt um segals flüchtigen
begegnungen platz zu machen
es gilt ein dokumentations- verbot denn
die kunst soll nur im moment existieren
das kunsthaus zürich hat vor ein paar
jahren ein werk von sehgal ausgestellt
und angekauft da keine dokumentation
existieren darf muss uns die kuratoren
das werk beschreiben und und sich
vorstellt mit name und ein sport oder
frage zum verlust hat mit ihm oder ihr
über marktwirtschaftliche frage zu
retten und wieder aufgeht dass wir das
macht dass wir am schluss von dem
sprecher der kasse vom museum und ein
teil von rund beim kauf einer segal
performance herrschen besondere
bestimmungen keine verträge nur
mündliche abmachungen
trifft sich mit dem künstler mit dem
gericht und jeder sieht dass käufer und
verkäufern und züge und tino sehgal
beschrieb den einfluss der beschriebenen
art installations- bedingungen also wer
da muss mitmachen und dann am schluss
von einer verhandlung gibt anschlag ist
ein radikaler erneuerer oder genialer
verkäufer die meinungen gehen
auseinander segals vergängliche kunst
verkauft sich inzwischen zu
höchstpreisen das flüchtige der
performance scheint sich doch in den
markt zu fügen
auch wenn auch längst nicht jede geste
zugeht